هل يبدو توقيت فتح التحقيقات مبكرا ام انه
توقيت
منطقي تحياتي لك استاذ نشوان ل
للمشاهدين يعني طرح موضوع لجنه التحقيق
وما تبع من من من تعميق للازمه الحاليه
وكان جزء من من من هذا السجال وهي الازمات
واعتقد انه اريد منه اصار رساله لبنيامين
نتنياهو وشركاه انه الرهان على الوقت
واستمرار الحرب الى ما لا نهايه وعدم فتح
الموضوع وما حدث بالسابع من اكتوبر وما
تلاه لن تستمر الى مد الى ما لا نهايه ولن
ننتظر نهايه الحرب التي لا تريدون لها
نهايه ونحن كجيش س نبادر من الان ان نحقق
مع انفسنا وهذا الذي يزعج بنيامين نتنياهو
وشركاؤه ان انه بدء بالتحقيق العسكري يعني
انه الامور ستطال المستويات السياسيه لن
يبقى المستوى السياسي بعيد عن عن لجان
التحقيق وسيفرض عليه ان تشكل لجنه تحقيق
رسميه و وستقوم بالتحقيق مع الجميع وهذا
يعني
انه نهايه الحكومه وانفراط عهدها وهذا
الذي يعني لا يريد نتنياهو ولا يريدوا
شركاء
نتن سي يعني توقيت فتح التحقيقات هو ليس
علامه على نهايه الحرب هذا ما
تقوله يعني نهايه الحرب بحاجه الى قرار من
قبل الحكومه الحكومه الحاليه ولا يوجد اي
انسجام ما بين مستوياتها السياسيه
والامنيه والعسكريه
اي الاجنده مختلفه المصالح الشخصيه
والاجنحه حاضره واخر ما يعني تركيبه
الحكومه الحاليه هو بين قوسين ما يسمى
الامن القومي ال لاسرائيل بالتالي هذه
الخلافات تعمق الازمه تخلق حالي من من من
التنافس العميق الكل يحاول ان يظهر
بالاكثر تطرفا وتشنج وتصلب وتوحش اتجاه
الفلسطينيين لذلك اعتقد انه زياره بلينكن
الى المنطقه تاتي في هذا السياق لانقاذ
اسرائيل من ذاتها اليوم شريحه واسعه
بالمجتمع الاسرائيلي اصبحت مقتنعه انه بق
اء المجموعه الحاليه على راس الهرم
السياسي والامني في اسرائيل سيقود اسرائيل
الى الى الى الهاويه يعني يعني غير مسبوق
لذلك اليوم يتعمد بنيامين
نتنياهو عدم طرح اي شيء له علاقه لا
باستمرار الحرب ولا بمرحله ما بعد الحرب
لانه بالنسبه له هذه الحرب يجب ان تستمر
الى ما لا نهايه وهذا بات يزعج الكثير من
الاسرائيليين وشاهدنا اليوم بالمظاهرات
التي جرت في اكثر من منطقه في حيفا في
قسار في تل ابيب في مناطق اخرى انه لم يعد
الشعار المرفوع هو اعاده الاسرى وانما
ايضا الذهاب لانتخابات واقاله الحكومه
واخراج
نتنياهو م من مشهد برمته واعتقد انه
بالايام القادمه سنرى تصاعد في هذا
الموضوع تصاعد بالحديث عن لجان تحقيق
واعتقد انه س ستنتقل الازمه الى الكنيست
في محاوله للبدء بحجب الثقه عن ه الحكومه
في فيما لو استطاعوا يعني ضم وتجنيد اعضاء
كنيست من الائتلاف الذي يشكل الحكومه
بالوقت الحالي بمعنى انه انه ها
الحكومه يعني باتت في نهاياتها اغلبيه
المجتمع الاسرائيلي باتوا يخافون من ها
الحكومه اكثر من خوفهم من حماس بعكس ما
يروج اليه نتنياهو وشركاه بانه هل هذا ما
يفسر ان اذا كانت المعلومه دقيقه هل هذا
ما يفسر ان نتنياهو هو من نسق الهجوم على
رئيس الاركان في الاجتماع الحكومي السابق
الذي شهد مشاهدات كلامي بالتاك بالتاكيد
لا يمكن لميري ريجف ودافيد مسلم ان
يهاجموا رئيس الاركان بحضور بنيامين
نتنياهو بدون التكليف ليس ضوءا اخضر انما
تكليفا من قبل نتنياهو وخاصه انه اصلا لم
يكن هنالك داعي لحضور دافيد مسلم وليس جزء
من من الكابينت نهائيا صحيح انه مكلف بما
يسمى الملف النووي ولكن هنالك تحفظ هنالك
يجب ان لا يكون بال باجتماع باجتماع
الكابينت وحضر وحضوره تم بناء على قرار من
بنيامين نتنياهو وبنيامين نتنياهو اصلا لم
يكن معنيا بطري موضوع ما بعد الحرب لذلك
قرر تفجير الموضوع و واشعال الازمه
داخل ان وان ينهي الاجتماع بفض وعدم
الحديث في في الموضوع الذي من اجله اصلا
عقد الاجتماع بالتالي هذا ما اراده
نتنياهو وهذا ما حدث ولكن اعتقد انه
تداعيات ستكون عكسيه تماما بعكس ما يريد
نتنياهو انه هذا عمق خشيه وقلق وخوف
المجتمع اليهودي من ان نتنياهو لم يعد
يابه نهائيا بمصلحه المجتمع الاسرائيلي
ولا باسراء ولا بما يسمى بالامن القومي
لاسرائيل بقدر ما يعنيه هو بقاءه بالحكومه
هو وشركاؤه والبقاء بالحكومه يعني اطاله
امد الحرب الى ما ل هايه وهذا الذي سيدفع
الكثير من من القوى بالبرلمان بالكنيست
الاسرائيلي وبقوه بالشارع الاسرائيلي
للعمل بشكل وبوتيرة